did you pick up star wars battlefront
season pass well you probably won't have
that option for the sequel I'm Tony and
this is your alternative gamespot news
update according to battlefront tues
creative director bound Deemer the game
won't have a season pass period instead
the team is doing quote something
different speaking to Mashable demers
stated I cannot talk about the specifics
of this but we have something different
in mind that will allow you to play
longer be more invested in the game
without having a fragmented community we
decided you know what for this type of
game season passes are not the best
thing we need to take it apart and come
up with something better it's important
to note that EA itself hasn't finalized
any season pass plans but we'll see what
the team cooks up when star wars
battlefront two launches on ps4 xbox one
and pc on november seventeenth be sure
to LIKE and subscribe to keep up with
all the new trailers and tidbits in the
meantime and for more from the galaxy
far far away check out our episode 9
trailer breakdown
[Music]